>>> TONIGHT IT'S BEEN MORE THAN
THREE DAYS SINCE THE FORMER
CHINESE PRESIDENT HU JINTAO WAS
ABRUPTLY ESCORTED OUT OF ONE OF
THE BIGGEST COMMUNIST MEETINGS
OF THE DECADE AND NO WORD, NO
IMAGE, NO SIGN OF HU.
THERE IS FOOTAGE SHOWING WHAT
HAPPENED BEFORE CHINA'S FORMER
LEADER WAS LED OUT OF THE ROOM
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERAS.
YOU CAN SEE ONE OF THE HIGHEST
RANKING MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNIST
PARTY SITTING TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S LEFT.
HE INTERVENES AS HU REPEATEDLY
TRIES TO READ FROM A STACK OF
PAPERS THAT ARE COVERED UP BY A
RED HOLDER.
LI TAKES IT AWAY.
WHILE THIS IS HAPPENING, XI GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS TO ANOTHER MAN WHO
PHYSICALLY LIFTS HU UP FROM HIS
CHAIR.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS, YOU
REALIZE THE ROLE THAT XI
POSSIBLY PLAYED.
SOME ARGUING IT WAS A POWER PLAY
BY XI.
OTHERS, INCLUDING STATE MEDIA,
SAYING THIS WAS ALL BECAUSE OF
HU'S HEALTH.
TO DATE, NO MEDIA OUTLET IN
CHINA HAS MENTIONED THE
INCIDENT.
BUT I WANT TO GO TO SELINA WANG
IN HONG KONG AND HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING THIS STORY.
SELINA, I WILL PLAY THIS FOOTAGE
AGAIN.
IT'S PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
HU TRIES TO READING IS WHO IS
TRYING TO HOLD ON TO THE FILE,
IT'S CLEAR.
LEE TAKES IT AWAY AND THEN XI
APPEARS TO BE, OBVIOUSLY, WHO
WAS JUST, JUST WON RE-ELECTION,
APPEARS TO BE THE ONE WHO GIVES
THE ORDER RIGHT BEFORE HU IS
LIFTED UP AND REMOVED.
WHAT DOES THIS VIDEO INDICATE TO
YOU?
>> YEAH, THIS IS REALLY
DEEPENING THE MYSTERY HERE.
THE VIDEO, IT DOESN'T DEBUNK THE
OFFICIAL STATEMENT THAT HE WAS
ESCORTED OUT BECAUSE OF HEALTH
REASONS.
BUT IT DOES SUGGEST THAT THE
DOCUMENT, WHICH WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S IN THAT DOCUMENT, DID
PLAY SOME ROLE IN ALL OF THIS.
NOW, HU IS 79 YEARS OLD, HAS
BEEN LOOKING INCREASINGLY FRAIL.
BUT A MOMENT MENTIONED AS
CHILLING THERE IS AS HE IS BEING
ESCORTED OUT LOOKING FRAIL AND
CONFUSED AND DISTRESSED, XI
JINPING AND THE LEADERS AROUND
HIM ARE LOOKING EMOTIONLESS,
STARING STRAIGHT AHEAD.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO EXPERTS WHO
THINK THERE IS MORE TO THIS THAN
THAT PURE HEALTH EXPLANATION,
INCLUDING THE SOAS CHINA
INSTITUTE.
THEY SAID THIS HUMILIATION OF HU
JINTAO.
THERE IS ONLY ONE LEADER WHO
MATTERS IN CHINA NOW AND THAT IS
XI JINPING.
THIS IS WRAPPED UP IN
SYMBOLSISM.
HU LED CHINA AT A TIME WHEN IT
WAS OPENING UP TO THE WORLD,
WHEN IT WAS GROWING RAPIDLY
ECONOMICALLY, HU LED WITH
COLLECTIVE LEADERSHIP.
XI JINPING STACKED UP TOP
POSITIONS WITH ALLIES, EX
CLOUDING SOME PEOPLE CLOSER TO
HU JINTAO, HE IS ALL ABOUT THAT
ONE MAN RULE.
>> AND WHAT'S AMAZING IS THAT
ENTIRE INCIDENT HAS BEEN
SCRUBBED FROM THE INTERNET IN
CHINA.
STATE MEDIA COVERAGE OF THE
CEREMONY DIDN'T INCLUDE THE
SCENE.
THE CHINESE STATE-OWNED
BROADCASTER CCTV BROADCAST,
THOUGH, A VIDEO OF HU SITTING
NEXT TO XI.
THEY SHOWED HIM VOTING BEFORE
THE INCIDENT.
IF YOU WERE IN CHINA, WHAT DO
YOU MEAN?
HE WAS THERE.
HE VOTED.
WHAT'S THERE TO SEE HERE?
DOES THE MAJORITY OF THE CHINESE
POPULATION EVEN KNOW THAT
ANYTHING HAPPENED?
>> Reporter: NO, THEY DON'T,
BECAUSE THIS VIDEO IS NOT BEING
SEEN IN OFFICIAL MEDIA.
IT'S SCRUBBED FROM DISCUSSION
FROM SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT'S AS IF THIS NEVER HAPPENED,
RIGHT.
AND WHAT THAT SCENE IS SHOWING
IS THAT IT WAS ALL STABILITY AND
CHOREOGRAPHY, THE SHOW WENT ON
AS PLANNED.
THAT IS WHAT THE AUDIENCE AT
HOME SEES.
THE FOCUS OF COVERAGE OF THE
PARTY CONGRESS TO THE PEOPLE IN
CHINA IS ALL ABOUT XI JINPING.
THE FOCUS IS ON HIM, HIS
SUCCESSES, HOW HE IS THE ONLY
MAN TO LEAD CHINA TO NATIONAL
REJUVENATION, GREATNESS, BUT HU
JINTAO HAS OVERSHADOWED XI IN
SOME WAYS.
>> IT'S AMAZING.
SO TWO VERY DIFFERENT STORIES.
ABSOLUTELY STUNNING THAT THEY
COULD CONTROL IT IN THIS WAY.
AMAZING THAT WE NOW HAVE THAT
NEW VIDEO AND TH